in Vietnam's Capital Hanoi the Mercury
is rising and so for many there's only
one option
[Music]
head for the pool
this year in comparison to previous
years is hotter more extreme
the heat wave has baked Vietnam for
weeks there's usually a hot period
before the rainy season but this year
it's been longer and more intense
that's got forecasters warning of a
possible drought and City officials
scrambling to save water
they're also saving electricity levels
and some of the hydropower dams are
lower than average and the surging
temperatures are putting pressure on the
National Grid as more people are using
air conditioning
if everyone saves energy then we'll have
enough electricity if not there'll be a
partial overload which will put the Grid
at risk
save power the city is turning off
street lights earlier than usual and
turning them on later prioritizing major
roads in public parks
offices and shopping malls have been
asked to halve their energy use and
people want to stay indoors in the
middle of the day
it's so hot and hot outside that people
have to wear protective clothing to cool
down and not get burned
Vietnam's not the only country in the
region suffering Laos and Thailand have
also reported their highest temperatures
on record in recent weeks last month the
Thai prime minister warned the heat was
becoming dangerous
earlier in May the head of the World
Meteorological organization said the
combination of a warming El Nino pattern
and climate change would push global
temperatures into Uncharted Territory
it's become even hotter over time in the
past 30 degrees Celsius was considered
hot but now we have to adapt to 40
degrees
weather experts say the Region's Heat
Wave could last a few more weeks with
the worst Yet to Come Alexia O'Brien Al
Jazeera
well China's first civil